Cái hoài khảan trái bây của Mỹ đang trở thành tâm điểm căn tháng mấy trong quanh hệ Washington
Bắc Kinh.
Các hạn hình không lớn của Trung Quốc như China, Eastern, China và China,
và China, Dạ gười thương lên bộ sau thông vận tải Mỹ.
Cảnh báo, miệng pháp này có thể kiến hành trình bây kéo dài thêm hai đến 8 tiếng.
Lâm tăng chỉ có nhiên liệu và nguy cơ chế trin đối.
Fí Mỹ li dài động thái này nhà bảo đam sự cạnh trình công bằng,
giò các hàng Mỹ hiện bị cấm mây qua không phải nha.
Kể từ khi xuống đột uống khu図 nạn lộ ra trong khi các hãng trụ quốc vẫn được phép bài.
Bộ ngoại gia trụ của trở sang để hạn chế này không có lợi trở xa lụng như dân
và sẽ gây tổn hại tới lợi đổi bên.
Nếu Washington quên đáp dụng lạnh cấm từ thả mởi một,
chua yvãn tại hàng không suyên thái bình dường có thể bị đạo lộ,
anh hưởng lớn tới hành khách và thường mạc của tế.